This is fun guy. These are some
of the 1.5 million types of fungi.
There's, here's the humongous
world of fungus fungi,
but one of the first organisms on earth,
billions of years ago,
fun guy or their own kingdom. They're
not animals, plants or bacteria.
Fungi live everywhere. Space
stations, deserts, deserts,
Antarctica, nuclear reactors. There's
plenty of shrew for all fungi.
Every day you walk on mushroom Mycelium,
not just mushrooms, root system,
mycelium communicates
information, transfers, nutrients.
It also builds soil that gives
life to all plants on earth.
Here is fun guy saving the world.
This is fun guys saving you.
There's fun guy for relaxation,
concentration,
energy and immune support.
This is you on shrooms tapping into
the humongous world. The fungus.
When I say to someone that I'm interested
in mushrooms or that I had a mushroom
company,
you get often few kinds of reactions.
Some are like I talking magic
mushrooms or and some are like gross.
I don't like the flavor of mushrooms and,
and some are really excited
for various reasons and but,
but they are a kingdom as you saw on the
video. And when something is a kingdom,
that means that there's a lot
of different kinds of things.
So if you think of all the
animals to live on earth,
there's quite a few kinds just in mammals
compare a Chihuahua and a blue whale
and they're drastically different,
right? And if you compare even plants,
not all plants are good for you.
I know obviously plant based
diet is right now a big thing,
a lot of people on it,
but a lot of plans will kill you
and mushrooms are no different.
Some of them will hurt you,
some of them will heal you.
And just to kind of get the
mushroom lingo out of the way,
mushroom is actually what
is called the fruiting body.
And fungi is a kingdom, right?
Fun guys like the umbrella.
But often people,
when they talk about the fungi kingdom,
they talk about mushrooms. But mushroom
is actually like the fruiting body.
So let's think of an apple
tree, for example, that fruit,
the actual apple would be
the fruiting body here.
That's the part that is
visible and you will eat.
It usually gets reproduced annually.
What some exceptions.
And then the rooting system,
which is often referred to as mycelium,
was also like high fade,
like an early Beta version of it.
But my psyllium is like the, the actual
apple tree itself, the bark and the roots,
right?
And there's a lot of mycelium underground.
So wherever you will go around the world,
they will be mycelium underground.
And then sometimes you'll see
these fruiting bodies popping up.
And the mycelium is really
important for environment.
And then my sale, the fruiting
body can be really helpful for us.
So since there's mycelium everywhere,
it serves a big purpose.
So about 2.4 billion years ago.
So if the earth is 4.24
point 5 billion years old,
2.4 billion years ago,
um,
my mushrooms or fungi came
from the seed to the dry land.
And what's actually fascinating about
mushrooms to me is that they're actually
very similar to animals.
So we're way closer as humans
to mushrooms than we are to,
for example, plants for example. Um,
mushrooms cannot produce their own food
through photosynthesis like plants can
they have to eat something.
By the way,
they also breathe oxygen and expel
CO2 just like just like animals.
But they need to eat something.
And since nothing else grew on dry land,
mushrooms decided to for a little
over a billion years eat rocks.
So they're survivors, you know. And then
later as plans were entered into the,
into to Earth,
the mushrooms help the plants to collect
water and nutrients from the soil.
And that happens still today.
So almost all plans that you will eat
have used fungi to collect water and
nutrients.
But this is not a biology lesson.
I'm not here to talk to you for
hours and hours about fun guy.
Some of you might find it fascinating,
some of you might not,
but just wanted to give you kind of
a quick overview. And the spores are,
by the way,
those are the seeds.
So you go from the rooting
system to the fruiting body.
The fruiting body will produce spores.
Boards are like the seeds and then the
sports will fly away and produce more.
Hi Faye and mycelium. So that's kind
of the lifecycle of a mushroom. Um,
my company four sigmatic is focused
on these functional mushrooms.
Those are like healthy mushrooms, often
sometimes known as medicinal mushrooms.
But since medicinal marijuana,
that's often a bad labeled.
These are completely legal safe,
nothing to do with psychedelics.
So that's why I prefer the
word functional mushrooms.
And these functional mushrooms are
all often also called adaptogens.
How many have heard the word
adaptogen? Could good bunch. Okay.
So this is right now really trendy.
It's actually not that a new of a concept.
It's just become very popular.
So adaptogen research started in
the Soviet Union for the army.
Um, what the army figured out, and this
is by the way, not just the Soviet army.
I had to go to,
I'm from originally,
if I'm thin then and I had
to go to the Finnish army.
At the same thing is in certain situations
the soldiers that given stimulants
amphetamine. For example, if
you're, I was in the air force,
you fly in a fighter jet,
you crash on an enemy territory,
pump you up a little effort to me in
and try to run as far as you can in the
next 24 hours. They'll hopefully
you'll be saved after that.
But what happens is that you
have a little bit of a let down,
a lighter version of a stimulant might
be like Adderall con lighter compared to
amphetamine or caffeine that
we often consume all the
time, right? So the Russian,
uh, with the Soviets were like, Hey,
is there anything else that we could
take which would perform performance,
maybe not as much,
but will improve performance that wouldn't
give you the let down the next day.
And they send this doctor,
Doctor Zirov, the research,
few things and loss of studied the best
things that he could find in the world
and came up with five things
that he thought were adaptogens.
And the word adaptogen comes from the
fact that it's helps you to adapt to
stressors.
So it helps you to adapt to stressors
and hopefully it will not give you a let
down. So I know something to be an
adaptogen, it needs three things.
It's non habit forming
means it's not addictive.
If something is addictive,
it cannot be an adaptogen,
didn't have to be something you could
take every day safely and you don't get
used to it. Secondly,
it is restores balance.
So erosion restores balance in your body.
And then finally it's nonspecific,
which is often, sometimes hard if you
have a scientific mind to figure out.
Cause scientific studies are usually
done on one single variable, one marker.
And when something is nonspecific,
it can help with the brain and the immune
function. And that can be complicated.
And that's where it's often in health,
like hormones for example,
or even though you have a
marker like testosterone,
it's sometimes complicated because
hormones go up and down, you pull a lever,
another one goes up or a doubt, right?
But that's what an adapted in Zuora.
That's what some of these best mushrooms
are as well. And these are, um,
kind of my passion. I would say. I'm,
I love fun guy and I love
the biology of fun guy,
but I'm mostly interested in is
what can the fun guy do for you?
How can it improve your cognitive
function, your immune system,
your skin?
Um,
I've been running my business
now for about seven years.
Normally I'd been traveling 40 to 60
times a year and during that time I've
lived in,
in the last 10 years I've lived in 10
countries and I've not been sick in 11
years. And one of the reasons
why I have to thank is,
is the use of adaptogens and
mushrooms for immune system.
But back to my story,
so I was brought up in Finland.
I'm a 13th generation farmer and
mushroom enthusiast and I was brought,
brought up to learn about
mushrooms through my mom,
my mom when I was like Yay high with my
brother. We went foraging for mushrooms.
And one of the first things that people
get wrong about mushrooms that they're
always grow in the ground.
They actually also grow on trees.
This is the Chaga mushroom
that we also use an uh,
the mushroom coffee that is outside.
And a lot of them are hard.
You can't eat them.
Actually you should not eat mushrooms raw.
Does the General Fund,
whatever mushroom we're talking about
don't have them rock cause they have this
structure called team that is
we humans are not really good at
absorbing. And there we lack
this enzyme. Um, think of a,
the shell of a lobster is made out of
Chitin so try eating a lobster shelf.
Not Good.
So you kind of have to process it.
But they are these beautiful creatures.
Most people just think of that
classic mushroom shape with the,
with which I showed you with the stem
and the cap and there's so many different
shapes and sizes,
different types of mushrooms and,
and some of the best ones growing trees.
Cause like I mentioned mushrooms like
animals, they need something to eat.
And often when people ask me like what
should you eat? What's a healthy diet?
I joked to them is that you
should eat dirt and trees.
The healthiest thing you can eat is
dirt and trees. Unfortunately not,
we're not equipped to
assimilate either of them.
So we need to eat something
that has eaten them.
So things that grow in the soil that had
minerals and then can get the good gut
biome from the soil into our body.
And also trees are incredibly healthy.
So obviously from maple
syrup to pine pollen,
but also these tree mushrooms that
serves so many different functions.
Um,
this is called Turkey tail.
This was called Rishi and a lot of
the mushroom names are a little exotic
cordyceps, which is used for
performance. That is the lion's mane.
This is right now one of the most popular
mushrooms in the U S it's a Toyota to
help with focus and cognitive function.
And it's funny how they look as well
is like lion's mane. Um, looks like a,
I guess like a main of alliance.
So that's how it's named that way.
But um,
my fascination with these is
mostly through the health benefits.
Like you saw in the beginning, video
mushrooms are used in almost have of,
of the pharmaceuticals out there.
Penicillin is the one you would know.
But out of the 20 best selling drugs and
and about 10 utilize fungi and they can
be used to clean oil spills. They can, uh,
help remove diesel from the
soil. Um, they can eat plastic.
Few years ago we found a
mushroom that eats plastic.
Plastic has been around a hundred,
hundred and 20 years.
And so far we haven't figured out what
kind of Wa wa does it a composed or not,
we don't know yet,
but we found a mushroom that likes to
eat it and then we can eat the mushroom
and it has health benefits.
But I think the environmental change is,
it's hard to change the world
through the environmental impact.
It's hard to change the
world to sometimes, um,
a lot of like very esoteric topics.
But what often people are first
interested in, hey, what can I do today?
The field good today, right. And
mushrooms can help with that.
Here's a little chart that
shows a mushroom Chaga,
which is this one girl was on a birch
tree. It grows for a 10 to 25 years.
So very slowly. And Birch has these
healthy compounds like Betalin and beds,
folinic acid. That's why if you
go to Finland or Russia, you get,
he hit yourself with birch leaves because
they have these healthy oils and the
bark and that kind of the mushroom kind
of eats them and then gets them in a
form that then we can utilize.
And the amount of antioxidants as
quite incredible. So antioxidants are,
are one of the things that are most
proven for general health and wellness in
the world. It's kind of a buzzy word.
People don't really know what it means,
but there are color pigments.
Not all color pigments are antioxidants,
but all antioxidants are color pigments.
It's like the champagne thing with the
sparkling wine and all sparkling wine,
champagne bottle, champagne
and sparkling wine, right?
And these color pigments can
help with cardiovascular health.
They can help protect our immune system.
A lot of the most common ways how people
die today and they can really help with,
um,
longevity and um,
and people off the internet
loves to debate Wah Wah.
Antioxidants are good and what they're on,
what has the highest amount,
but just for the sake, the two big
bubbles are how two different ways,
how you can press it,
process a wild Siberian Chaga,
and then you have some of the other
more antioxidant rich foods from dark
chocolate too aside Barry.
And this gives you an idea how abundant
these mushrooms are in these nutrients
and how potentially you
could benefit from them.
And that's chart on how to use them.
So mushrooms are often
used for most people.
They're used in like pizza or pasta or
something like the very narrow focus.
People mostly focus on Porta Bella and
like crimeny type mushrooms may be she
talkie and she talk is a good mushroom,
but a lot of these culinary
mushrooms are not that good.
They grow in the ground and
they're not that nutrient dense.
They're kind of like mass produced. Think
of like your normal culinary mushrooms,
almost like, like iceberg
lettuce versus a Rugala, right?
There's nothing wrong
with iceberg lettuce,
but the clearly nettle or dandelion
or Rugala has a lot more, you know,
punch and the same with
mushrooms. And, um,
when we talk about, um,
generally about mushrooms,
it's like anything is
like you have really good,
really average and then really bad things.
And that's where actually my company and
four sigmatic also stems from is just
geeky out of math.
So if you take all the worlds foods,
there's roughly like let's say 1.8 million
things you can eat and you put it on
a bell curve,
get and compared their nutrient density,
it will form a normal distribution.
And this is normally a science
including natural sciences.
If you take a large enough sample size,
you look at single variable.
I see how tall are people or,
or how,
what is their Iq tends to
form an Olam and distribution,
the food side of the same. And if you
look at their nutrient dense city,
most foods are just normal good.
Some,
some are like solid health foods
and then some foods are kind of bad,
right?
And if you go for a standard deviations,
which I know sigmas they go
four standard deviations,
you get to the top 50 foods in the world,
right? And out of those top 50 foods,
there are things like lemon, black
pepper, cinnamon, coconut, green tea,
a Cacau, things that, you know,
then there's foods that you might know
like turmeric or gin sang or Makkah.
And then there's really foods
that very few people know,
like the Reishi mushroom
more stragglers route. And I,
I'm just passionate about the things that
are the most currently scientifically
studied foods.
And funny enough,
those tend to be also the foods that
have been used the longest throughout
different cultures.
So every part of the world tends to
have their own like foods that they've
elevated to kind of,
um,
a sacred status over multiple generations.
And every generation after that has
thought that that food is special for some
reason.
So if you go to Bali or Costa Rica or
you go to Finland and Russia or you go to
Africa, you will find certain
foods are elevated over others.
And that's what I'm most passionate
about. And out of those 50, about 10,
our mushrooms, that's our farm
where I grew up. And I think the,
besides the health benefits of mushrooms,
the one thing that I really want to
kind of leave you today with is just
generally about how what it
takes to do something new.
I feel like the talk,
the topic was like how to dirt moved
from dirt to gold and I think that's the
lesson that I've learned over the years
of coming from a small farm in Finland
to Venice Beach,
California and building a business and
creating companies like understanding
that in order to create
value or capture value,
you have to see on devalued things.
Okay,
so any form of business beat
investing or something else,
you're trying to find an acid or a thing
that has more value than other people
think. Like you think the stock is
worth $10 but the market things,
it's $5 if you buy it at five you think
eventually the market will know it's
worth 10 right? The same with if you
start a business or you have an idea,
you try to find something that
others don't yet see or they see it,
but they don't understand the
true value and power of it.
So probably let's say Google in the early
days there were people who thought, oh,
search engine, it has value,
right? It's some value.
But then people didn't see what's the
implications of having that value and how
you can transport it to other factors.
And then investors are Google
probably made, you know,
good profit by seeing that it
was an undervalued asset. Right?
So I'm from,
uh,
I'm from a town of maybe like 150
people and I'm there, you know,
like I didn't travel growing up and I,
my dream is to get Americans to drinking
mushrooms. That's a pretty radical idea,
right? So it's like I came here, I
had started the business and I'm like,
I told everyone is like,
hey,
I want to get the whole of
America drinking mushrooms.
Cause that's the most ancient way of
actually consuming these tree mushrooms.
And I know their benefits
and people like you're crazy.
Nobody drinks mushrooms
around here. Right? So,
but I believed in it,
which is kind of one of the three tips
I want to leave you guys today with from
the business side is if,
if if you want to achieve anything,
you have to be super passionate
about it and believe in it.
And the second thing is that hopefully
whatever you do is based on some first
principles with me it was science,
understanding the research
amount of mushrooms,
understanding their history and
their culture implications and also
understanding how to prepare them. And
so you, you can't just make up stuff.
It needs to be based on some sort
of like first principle or a logic.
And then finally is like as you
start building the business,
um,
you know,
forget remembering why you started this
is I was a couple of weeks ago in lap
plan with bunch of friends.
Um,
it was minus 39 degrees and went to
frozen water. It's actually below,
it's like 25 degrees. There's a
stream that keeps the water open.
Like this is the culture.
Why I started the business is the
Finnish culture and the culture of like a
natural living. And then I moved to
California to build the business.
And sometimes the life here is not
as natural as it was at a farm,
but it's like really important for me as
I go to remind myself why I started the
business. So, um, uh,
this is the he culture.
This is the only indigenous
culture in Europe. Um, uh,
partly partly in Finland as well.
And how they use mushrooms is one of
the sources of inspiration for me.
And here's examples of products that
we do like mushroom coffee and mushroom
chocolate lattes won this tonics.
And,
and one of the reasons why
we do this is that mushrooms,
the healthy mushrooms don't
taste anything like Portabella.
They actually tastes very bitter and
most Americans don't like bitter.
So when I came here and I
made like mushroom tea, people
are like, this is gross.
I first of all, I don't like tea.
Second meat, I don't like this flavor.
So I had to kind of reverse engineer
and figure out what are the bitters that
Americans like or most angle
section culture is like.
And I figured out there's only a
couple coffee and chocolate, um,
black coffee and dark chocolate with some
of the only bidders that were commonly
available to people.
So using those pallets and those delivery
systems as incorporating into people's
lives. But um, to kind of recap, um,
just some of the books I've written,
one about the history of the
Samei people want cook book,
how to use mushrooms and, and about
the top 10 mushrooms. But to recap,
kind of my talk is, um, I believe in the
power of mushrooms. I think they're, uh,
uh,
an organism much smarter than we realize.
I think they're an undervalued and
that's why I'm also excited to build a
business around them.
I believe a lot in their power for myself,
but also I believe that you should focus
on doing something that is undervalued
and getting people to understand the
value. Then that's also smart business.
Um, I think if you want to
learn more about mushrooms,
there's a lot of resource
that you can go to. I can rip,
highlight too few books and um,
and learning methods how are
you can learn about them.
And I think in the next 10 years we'll
see multiple different research coming
out from mushrooms for health benefits,
for cognitive function, for immune system.
That I think will shock a lot of people.
And uh,
that gets me excited every day to
just start building four. Sigmatic.
But with that,
um,
if you have any questions about the
health benefits on forcing Madec or the
mushrooms in general,
if you have questions on,
on anything mushroom related,
happy to take it.
Yeah. This isn't about mushrooms, but, um,
seals eat mushrooms. Does that
mean snails are healthy too? Um,
yes and no. So not big as they eat
mushrooms. That's not the reason.
So there's sort of mammals that eat
mushrooms, bears, deer, rabbits,
they're sort of insects
that eat mushrooms.
That doesn't mean that that's
why that species is good for you.
But I would say generally, uh, we
are very focused as a culture on,
on large mammals that have flesh.
This is like a complete
separate topics from health.
We're really obsessed about just
eating few types of animals.
So that classic debate is
[inaudible] animals with,
shoot I not I'd animals but often it's
coming from a lens of eating mostly large
mammals that are very domesticated,
that are almost always female.
We almost own the EAD women.
So, uh, we don't eat bull,
we eat the cow,
we don't eat like a boar.
We the female a chicken the same.
We don't eat the rooster and we very
highly processed animals and we don't even
eat the whole piece of that animal.
We mostly focused on the flesh
part versus like the liver and the,
the eyeballs and all
the things that people,
most people think it's gross is actually
like really nutrient dense and a lot of
insects and smaller animals tend to be
healthier actually cause they're lower in
the food chain.
So you tend to be like the Lord you're
in the food chain and early you are the
cleaner it is.
Or if you go further in the food chain
and you go to bigger animals or even
bigger fish, you have to be
more careful about the quality.
So it's usually safer to eat
a small fish than a big fish,
but you really have to know
what the big fish is coming. So,
but it's not because they eat mushrooms.
That's why snails a healthy,
they just are.
Yeah.
Can you pass the mic to,
you can throw it.
I uh, thanks for the talk. Yeah. Uh,
you raised the point about bitterness.
Uh, I was just wondering like,
have you found yourself, uh,
compromising and the healthiness of the
mushrooms by like adding sugar at any
point or,
yeah,
most of our products don't have sugar and
I don't really believe in adding sugar,
especially processed sugar.
We have a couple products
that have coconut palm sugar,
about two grams per serving. Awesome. And
coconut palm sugar is a lot healthier,
has more minerals.
And is it more kind of diabetic friendly
but don't believe in adding sugar?
We use things like monk fruit and
Stevia and certain products and certain
products or just unsweetened,
it's kind of this healthy balance of
like knowing where the market is and
knowing where you want to get to. Right.
And kind of like bridging the gap.
So let's assume you want really
technology. I'm from Finn than we are.
We love like, like my SQL and
leanings and all this stuff.
Lean never really got big
accepting servers just because
partly because they use
are in the phase was it was not
the easiest to use. Right. And um,
and,
or even know Kia where our farm is,
is like think of Nokia leading the mobile
technology and then apple taking over.
And it's partly because apple is just,
iPhone was just so much easier
to use for most people. Right.
And Nokia's weren't always not.
And the same here is like,
if my dream is to get here,
but consumers are here,
how do I meet them in the middle?
How do I make a product that is a little
more bitter than what they're used to?
A little less sweet, a little less
artificial. Still healthy. Yeah.
But I kind of meet them because
without compliance there's no change.
There's no like you can buy a pass
to the gym but you feed never go.
It doesn't help you. So rather do
a shitty workout than no workout.
So in this case the same thing.
But yeah, I wouldn't add, um,
I wouldn't add much sugar or any sugar
to these products because I think it
jeopardizes the main function,
which is kind of being more like anti
inflammatory and protecting the immune
system. And when you add
the sugars and sweeteners,
it can kind of do the opposite.
Mushrooms can also balanced
blood sugar and support, um, um,
blood sugar management.
So when you kind of do that,
it kind of counterbalances the benefit.
So. Yeah. That's great. Thanks. Yeah,
so I've heard a formulating new products
and bring them to market is like a
multi year process and it takes
a lot of r and D and energy for.
Um,
I'm curious,
you have a lot of different products
that keep seeing new stuff that you
introduce quite regularly.
How long is your design process,
by the way? Thank you for
asking that. The, you're the
first person to ever ask it.
I'm very passionate about this topic.
So I'm the, like the product founders.
If we will be a tech company, I would
be like loving to make the code myself.
And I'm like, this is a really a
topic that I could talk for days.
So you're right, most of the people take
multiple years to build a product. Uh,
for us,
my goal is two months realistically
where three but it's still drastically
shorter than for most people.
And that requires a few fundamental things
to be in place to innovate so quickly.
So obviously like sourcing ingredients,
any ingredients that are going to use,
you have to be really good at that.
So you have to have a baseline
infrastructure of like, hey dude,
why do you get products?
But that's still like somewhat easy to
solve where most even large companies
take years to develop a product
and they don't succeed with it.
And I think one of the
key things why we've been
successful in a short while, um,
building products is a couple
of fundamental things that
I think is transferable
to any industry, any product,
any situation. First of all,
being close to the end consumer,
right? Lot of people who,
especially large companies try to
create products from an ivory tower.
They send out surveys and
focus groups and whatever,
try to figure out what's the trend.
They read reports and I think
they're already from them.
They're behind the curve versus every day
engaging with the consumer and knowing
what's out on the market and
listening to their needs and wishes.
So we do tons of community work
in person, uh, to meet people,
to talk with them and
being in that interface.
So whatever you're trying to build,
the more time you can spend or actually
even be the consumer who I think ims as
well as everyday using these products
myself is easier. The R and D is,
and the more removed you
are from the end consumer,
target consumer or that lifestyle or
the industry, whatever the harder days,
right? Sometimes you can get too
close to it. Yes. But nevertheless,
like the closer you are to interface.
So I could come out with 20 to 30 product
ideas in an hour just by looking my
own lifestyle in different parts
of my day, a week, a month,
a year, and figure out where the gaps,
where I need optimal performance.
So where do I need a boost and enhance
a support and it would be so easy.
And then you kind of pick your
battles like what is easy to execute,
why has big upside?
And then the other thing that is very few
people have is it besides the customer
proximity or the customer interface with
with products is that they think they
have to be right.
And I think even our best products
are currently best selling products.
I've gone through multiple iterations and
I think if you remove your ego and you
just have like, Hey, I have a thesis.
This is what I hope to get eye health,
gut health. Okay. I think most people
that gut is messed up because a, B,
and c and this time of the day they
need support. Hey, this is my idea.
Let's bring this light to make
healthy lemonade, whatever it is,
and then you're trying to innovate for it.
And then he'd come with the concept
of the market. You let people try it,
they give you feedback and then you
iterate. Most large companies especially,
they want to get the product be so
good from the get go and probably,
I mean Gmail or something like that has
gone through seemingly so similar calm
through, you know, hundreds of thousands
of iterations over the years. Right?
And that's us how it is.
And I think most people try to
get a perfect product from the,
from the beginning.
And that's a big failure.
So we have a big direct to
consumer business besides
the retail business with um,
whole foods and Erewhon and Sephora
and whoever we work with. Um,
but with that online kind of like
email list and our community,
we can test products really
quickly and within like 30 days,
we saw how many people bought it.
We can send them a survey,
ask them what they think
in 45 days to 60 days.
We know how many people have those repeat
purchases and then we already have a
good baseline understanding
of how to make it better.
So being really close to the customer
and not being scared to fail or be ready
to iterate,
like we assume that we will not get it
right and we assume that we need to tweak
it and amended over the ghost.
And we also assume that some of them like
have the products will be discontinued
at some point.
You're more likely to create
more innovation versus if
you're always scared to
fail, then you're kind of be
frozen and you try to perfect it.
So I don't know if that helped with that.
Yeah.
Yeah. Hey, uh,
I got here a little late so I don't
know if he covered the salary,
but that's like, um, what was, uh,
some of your biggest challenges to
like growth in the early stages?
Like getting your first customer.
Like what did that look like?
What did you switch? Should have you
spent more time, which should have you
de prioritized, I guess getting
through that initial hurdle where you,
no one knows who four sigmatic
is suddenly, you know,
you have your first customer,
what does that look like? Sure.
So I started the company in Europe and
then when I brought it to us, so I have,
I have to go twice through the process
when I was like first getting the first
customer in Europe and then came to the
u s and nobody cares about what you did
in Europe that Americans just don't care
at all. So he kind of had to restart.
So when I started in Europe,
it was actually really easy for me to
get the first customers because I was in
that industry and I had tons of friends.
So the first 50 to a hundred people,
I was just like friends
that people I knew,
which is really valuable because you
get really get feedback really quickly.
But he was a lot harder to scale.
So in Europe it was easy
to get initial traction,
but then harder to scale for us.
And some of the things I spend a lot of
time focusing in on is the ingredient
and sourcing,
which is like the geeking out part.
And unfortunately in most
consumers don't care.
But it was important for me to know
that I had like the best raw materials.
I don't regret it,
but it definitely took a lot longer.
The second thing is that I didn't raise
venture funding, I didn't have capital.
So even if you had success just
by not having a lot of cash,
you have to kind of
really slowly chip away.
And that was a big hurdle having patients
because as an entrepreneur you want
everything to happen overnight
and just crush it and kill it.
And when you didn't have cash and you had
a big dream of getting people to drink
mushrooms and nobody drank mushrooms,
it was like really hard.
So having patients and,
and then figuring out how to scale,
I had initial traction,
but how to scale was really
difficult in the beginning. Um,
and then if I say something other than
that is like the flavor was as something
that we focused a lot on. And if you
don't have a food or beverage product,
just the user ease of user experience is
kind of maybe the touch point is like I
as I was so obsessed with the technology
and the ingredients versus not enough
with the flavor and the ease of
use straight out of the gates.
And then when I came to the u s the
challenge was being an immigrant.
I've lived in multiple countries,
but this is the only country where it
really felt like it was hard to open a
bank account. You know, everything
was so difficult and um,
that took a lot of time and it was
harder here to get the initial traction.
But then when it's scaled and scaled more
beautifully, there's just one language.
One currency versus Europe is multiple
languages, multiple, you know,
Lee legally just the hassle,
the u s it was just easier to scale.
And I had already thought about that
scaling and what I've would have hoped I
focus even more on is sound.
The thing that we,
people think we did really well,
but I just think you can never do it well
enough is storytelling and community.
And if you ask people in the industry,
they often know that we
build an awesome community,
but I've wished I would have even doubled
down on that and maybe focus a little
less on kind of the minutia of,
of,
of just like retailers and caring about
the industry stuff, the B2b folk stuff.
I should have focused even less on an
even more double down on community and
storytelling and, and get those,
those made it even better. So I got,
so I want to sort of silo in on,
on one point there. Yeah. Um,
so what would you say was your best
growth channel in that early stage?
Was it content? Was it, you know,
building a community? Was it Instagram?
Was it purely growth marketing wise?
Um,
our success because we didn't have
money and I couldn't do any, so there,
if there's t three types of media, there's
paid, owned and earned. We mostly eat,
killed it with the,
with the earned and through influencers
is because your favorite health
influencers, favorite influencer
probably used our products.
It's still today if you think of the
person you go to in health advice,
whoever they go to for health advice,
use our products.
And through that we had this constant
and I credibility and like support from
people that it really mattered and
that helped us grow into the one phase.
And then soon after that, um, we
started winning with like podcasts.
Like that was a big thing for us is
because podcast allowed long form content.
Our topic is not easy.
It's not bullet sizable.
You can sell it on as easily on um,
uh,
22nd 15 second Instagram
story or something like that.
He requires deeper explaining
and trust. I was like, hey,
mushroom coffee sounds gross.
I definitely don't want to try that.
But if somebody you trust says is actually
doesn't taste like mushrooms and it
makes me feel awesome, you should
try it, you're more likely to try it.
So on the kind of second
wave long forms content,
really worked for wealth for
us predominantly podcast,
but also long email marketing, blog
post, other educational forums.
But the Spi podcast was,
I think still podcast is so
undervalued as a form of, uh, as a,
as a growth way for any, any
product or service. Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, I found out
through Tim Ferriss,
so now. Cool. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
so I'm curious how you were talking about
sourcing and then you also mentioned
how,
uh,
large scale mushroom production
kind of lost its nutrition. Um,
and then I was also thinking about,
I've read that truffle production is down
about 99% over the last hundred years
due to like too much harvesting of wild
truffles and they're hard to grow in
microrisal and whatnot.
Um,
so how do you view a sourcing and
maintaining quality and the sustainability
thereof?
Yeah, definitely. Again, a
topic, thanks for asking. Like,
I don't think a lot of
people focus on that.
There's a lot of foods that have become
popular at Saint Chia seeds or Makkah
and then suddenly people like
we can't actually produce that.
That would be like Internet kind of
made few things really popular really
quickly.
And agriculture is a slow moving thing.
It's like it doesn't change overnight.
You can't just physical
agriculture doesn't, you can't
just, it takes a long time.
And farmers are usually are risk adverse
and a little bit is like they're not
going to change their plans
because Instagram influencers
to sell Chia seeds or
something like that.
So with mushrooms we were about one
third of our mushrooms are wild crafted,
two thirds are grown on
logs and if wildcrafting is
the hardest part and the La
growing is the easier part
because it's Super um,
good yield. So dollar per
square feet is a really high,
so you take trees that are already dead
because that's their natural habitat.
A lot of these mushrooms grow on debt
or decaying trees. You drill a hole,
it would a spore and they
will grow a mushroom that
you can for that square food.
You can get a lot of money.
So there is that part is a little easier,
especially when you talk to people
who understand what mushrooms to grow.
So and mushrooms or extra fields.
So they grow really easily,
is it you just give them
the right environment.
So that to third part is the easy that
wildcrafting crafting was the hardest
part, right? Because you have to actually,
somebody needs to go to the forest and
pick up a piece of Chaga to get this.
And I could talk for this for hours.
Um,
the one benefit we had is Finland is
a small country, but it's bordering.
I used to have the,
one of the biggest economic borders in
the world between Finland and Russia and
Russia starting from thin than they have
just happens to have the largest force
in the world called Taiga,
ta Iga.
And that's a forest size of United States.
So one forest size of United States,
right.
And that forest is predominantly perfect
for a birch tree that happens to grow
Chaga and he happens to
grow pretty much everywhere.
And you just need to kind of know
where it grows and how to collect it.
But it's more like
education on harvesters and,
and telling them where to
get in and how to get it.
That was like operational and it a
little bit more difficult. Um, but yeah,
it takes a lot of thinking and
most people don't focus on it.
They just read on our block that
outside berries, good for you.
And then let's say a loss Iberia.
And they don't never think about the
supply chain until they're much later in
the process.
And this is even with college and right
now there's like most college and brands
are,
they don't have enough college and to
sell because college has become popular.
And I don't know if you know
how you may collagen basically,
usually a boy like the hides and the bones
and you kind of skim the cream on the
top and it's like a quite the process and,
and it was just the waste product before
Kiner and now it's become like every
um,
yeah,
beauty person is trying to use college
and every athlete's trying to use college
and as the p the demand just went sky
high and few years and people are like,
hey,
we don't have enough of this.
So now they have trying to figure out how
else can we produce Collagen. So yeah,
most entrepreneurs don't think about that.
So thanks for asking that. Thank you.
I love this by the way,
you can throw it.
Thanks for your talk has
been really interesting. Um,
how do you go about picking which
mushrooms are going to end up in,
in the te products or
the coffee products and,
and how do you figure out what the
benefits are that you can advertise
associated with the
mushrooms that you've picked?
Sure. So that's actually easier than
with most food products with mushrooms.
Because you have to cook them
cause they're not bioavailable raw.
It's like a rock. There's few
outside if you want to try them.
So you have to cook them kind
of like you would do bone broth.
So you do this like decoction so you cook
it for a long time and because you can
control the temperature and the amount
of mushrooms you can standardize your
certain strength.
So it's almost like cooking it for
days to a standardize it to a certain
strength of coffee and it's a very easy
lab test just to make you have a strong
enough team.
So some years you have to
use more mushrooms than
other times and sometimes you
can use less.
Sometimes we have to cook it longer or
shorter so you can just control the,
the process to get standardized output.
So yeah,
it's actually that part is quite easy
to engineer but you just need to,
sometimes you have more mushrooms so
sometimes we're more profitable than other
times.
I guess that's the other way to say it
is sometimes it costs more to make that
cup and sometimes less.
And then for figuring out like
what the health benefits are,
is that like historically based
like yeah, traditions. Yeah.
And if I may comment on that,
that's a,
that's a common theme that I hope us as
a consumers will be more educated on is
we want everything standardized.
And I don't think nature works like
that our product is standardized,
but I would hope that we as consumers
can accept the fact that sometimes that
the nutrient density of the food we
buys higher or lower depending on
seasonality and what you eat.
And I think us expecting always to
get the same flavor, same result,
is forcing us to eat actually worst
food because then the producers have to
produce a product like that.
The apple to always taste the same and
it's just nature doesn't work like that.
So if we can accept some variability
in flavor and nutrient density,
as long as we know the baseline,
a sourcing that will be actually better
for the world than always expecting the
chocolate to taste the exactly the same
because even chocolate has seasonal
variety. But to your second question
about nutrient density. So, um,
the benefit of mushrooms is that about
40% of pharmaceuticals use mushrooms.
So there's, there's a lot of research
funding for fungal research. Um,
this is unfortunately, there's not a
lot of research funding for whole foods.
So of all foods, even let's say
blueberry, which is people generally,
everybody knows it's healthy
and it's very, it's been a
long time. It's research.
There isn't that much research on
blueberries, you know, cause it,
who would fund that? There's no economic
interest on blueberry research. A,
if somebody research booberry they want
to isolate a compound and I'm the CNN in
the blueberry that is good for eyesight.
And then we'll brand it us the Laskin
on the CNN and they will put it in
supplements and sell it.
But,
so that whole food research by at large
is so limited versus something that you
can patent because you
can't pass in whole foods.
But lucky enough because mushrooms,
there is a lot more of them.
I would recommend if you want to look
at any food product pup met is kind of a
database for various just research.
You can put the Latin name
of any food you can get.
Roughly the amount of research than
fact that there's 5,000 research papers
doesn't mean it's healthy. You know,
the most research fruits in the world,
our tobacco number one and
marijuana and number two. Um,
soon after that you get to things like
lemon and Ginseng and other things like
that. So it doesn't guarantee if something
is well researched that it's healthy,
but it gives you a pretty good oversight
or what it is good for. And Mushrooms,
she talky Rishi, things like
that are very well studied. Um,
so you look at their general research
and you figure out that they're good for
like maintaining a blood glucose levels.
They're good for gut health.
You kind of like give oversight and
then we make first just to be safe side,
we make buffery claims.
So instead of saying is that you will be
smarter when you consume our products,
we say, hey, this is like
a hug from your grandma.
And then you can do
the rest. But um, yeah,
it's baseline on just heart science on uh,
um,
a genus of anything. And then looking
at what is it generally good for,
how well is it's research who
researched it, how they researched it,
and then you kind of try to apply it
into a food product. Um, but yeah,
I mean just unfortunately there just
isn't a lot of whole food research since
you can't own that research, you can't
patent it. So, right. So challenge
one if you want to,
I'm just curious to know
about your mushroom diet,
like how you use these products and what
kind of mushrooms they use and how do
you cook them and all that kind of stuff.
So I don't answer that question partly
ever including I don't answer how I eat
because people want a shortcut and how
I eat is not necessarily how you should
eat or how I use mushrooms
is not necessarily how you
should use mushrooms. Also,
how I use mushrooms in February,
2019 is not hot necessarily.
I'll use them in March. March is a
busier month for me than February.
So maybe when I'm busy I have to use
different things to support my busy
lifestyle. Right. Um, I had
that one slide somewhere here.
Give you a rough idea of timeframes.
So generally speaking,
like you don't necessarily want caffeine
in the morning because your cortisol
already spikes.
A lot of people love it as a method,
but you're naturally should be energetic.
You should probably go outside,
get some fresh air,
maybe move a little bit,
but you want to hydrate and you probably
want antioxidants like a shield,
a bodyguard for the day.
So mushrooms like Chaga and
she to that have a lot of sod.
Super Oxide dismutase is
this super antioxidant.
Using things like that might be really
good for the day to kind of get started.
And then in the afternoon when you need
a little pick me up using something like
lion's mane that boost cognitive function
or using something like core to steps
that gives you energy without caffeine
or sugar might be a good idea.
When you naturally get that
little dip in the afternoon,
the best scenario is you
taking a nap or a Siesta.
But if that's not possible because of
work, maybe try something like that.
And then the evening time
you one things that um,
support somehow kind of
calming down process.
So Rishi is used for kind of like kind
of the endocrine system, the HPA axis,
kind of calming your body.
It's known as the Queen of Mushrooms
maybe will help you reach deeper sleep.
And then she talked a good help with
phase one and two liver detox that often
happens over night.
So that might be a good strategy
if you want to cleanse your liver.
Liver is a kind of a mirror
to skin health as well.
So there are different
times how you can use it.
I just never answered how I use it.
You just have to figure out yourself.
I know it's not the answer people want
because they want to formula do a,
B and c, but uh, maybe that
gives you some framework. Yeah.
I wasn't looking for a formula.
I was just curious how you apply
this a lot different ways and uh,
yeah, and high quality. That's my three,
four thanks varieties,
huge bubble.
Even if you can have an adaptogen, you
can use everyday varieties. Awesome.
So even with dark leafy Greens,
even if it Rugal is awesome
or dandelion is awesome,
try all kinds of Greens and just
kind of mixed them, match them.
And same with mushrooms.
It's beneficial to mix and match them.
And so even though I'm not a fan of
Portabella, you can still have it, uh,
just get different varieties into a
system. And the more variety you have,
the more intelligence you're
getting from food into your, uh,
into your cells and into
your DNA. Yeah. Sorry,
I might've missed this when you
were talking about scaling, but, uh,
in terms of a timeline, uh,
I was wondering what was the,
how long did it take for you
to go from zero or not zero,
but like a product idea to get like a
package product ready for the market?
Um, it took about two years on the
first time because you have to solve the
operational challenges, which
is, is harder for me than
the, the product concept.
So the first time sourcing ingredients,
getting a partner who
can make the packaging.
That took a lot longer than coming out
with the wisdom and the vision and the
use case. So that was easier for me. But
maybe for another founder it's different.
But if you've never done food
or beverage manufacturing,
I highly recommend having patients that
he might take a lot longer to actually
get the product produced than you think.
If you have a donut that everybody,
all your neighbors love your donut and
your friends and family and saying,
you should make this donut. It's
a hit, it's a great doughnut.
And then you figure out that you've been
making at home and now you need an FDA
approved commercial kitchen or
contract manufacturer to make it.
It could take a lot longer than you think.
So it took about two years
to get the first version out.
Partly was my incompetent,
like not just me,
just not knowing enough of the details.
It probably takes about a
year and normally just to
cut every paperwork in order.
And for me it took two years just because
I didn't know all the details too.
Like did you have to
do most of it yourself?
Or they're like contractors that do it.
Like a bunch of different,
I had to do most with myself and my
founding team because nobody had done what
we did. Nobody had done a dual
extracted Warcraft and mushroom.
Nobody had done it so they
have to figure that out.
Nobody had done these
packaged mushroom beverages.
They were sold in capsules
or in big ground bag.
So I have to figure out how to book these
mushroom powders in packets that look
like almost like emergency or a tea back
that you can just pour in a cup and add
hot water. I got to figure out that
kind of stuff and there wasn't,
but if you ever think of
doing a dietary supplement,
there's like hundreds of
companies that can help do it.
If you want to make a beverage yourself,
there's hundreds of companies making it.
I would just highly recommend is that
don't outsource r and d and IP fully to
someone ever. Like, even if you use
their resources for certain things,
always have really engage you or someone
else in the team really engaged in that
process. So you know, a how it's done.
So it's easier for you to
sell on marketing because
you know, it was like, Hey,
is it you?
How has this natural orange flavor made?
Is it from a squeeze from an orange or
how do we get this orange flavor into
your product? That's like a
question somebody might ask you.
So you know the answer. But
second, the as well as like,
then you own the technology because in
food and beverage there really isn't the
same way quarter technology
and that you have and in it,
so be really engaged. And there's
definitely a lot of resources for beauty,
skincare, protein, food
and beverage. Just for me,
there wasn't because nobody
had done what we did. Yeah.
Okay.
Last one.
Just when it comes at you catch it.
So you've talked about mushrooms,
you know, breathing and uh,
and the eating and being a smarter food.
Um,
are you saying that mushrooms have like a,
a type of consciousness
that is measurable?
Yes,
that's what I'm exactly saying.
And you can measure it and they've
measured it multiple times.
They put mushrooms in a maze and funny
enough the mushroom finds its way out of
the maze.
They put mushrooms to figure out how
to build that their subway system in in
Tokyo or actually the railway system in
the UK and the mushroom figured out how
to build a railway system more efficient
than what humans had built. So yes,
it is measurable.
I also think that the most interesting
intelligence that mushroom have of global
consciousness is not measurable
and we have no clue of it.
And I think we will not have a
cool of it for a long, long time.
And that will be a whole nother talk
about the consciousness of mushrooms.
But yes, I think they're higher beanie.
I'm just leaving you with a nugget.
Planting a seed is that mushrooms almost
always live with bacteria and bacteria
almost always lives with mushrooms.
So right now in your body there's about
10 times more bacteria than you have
cells in your body.
And there's a lot of cells and almost
always this bacteria lives with mushrooms.
If you take Kombucha,
it's a symbiotic organism,
basically brewed black tea with a
little bit of sugar that interacts with
bacteria and fungi. If you
think of fermented foods,
Sauerkraut, Kimchi, whatever,
and right now we've talked about how your
gut is your second brain or your first
brain, how we talk about your
gut instinct, your spider sense,
how you just know something, you can't
explain it in words, but you feel it,
you know it.
And it's often related to your gut biome,
which is now a big research topic.
And how that got biome is actually tied
into probiotics and prebiotics and how
those prebiotics live with the bacterial
kingdom and the fungal kingdom.
And they have knowledge that
we've yet to figure out.
And I think that knowledge
is much greater than us.
And they found mushrooms growing
at every level of the atmosphere.
Mushrooms can survive in space.
So they've traveled a long
ways and different places.
And I think I'll probably,
I don't think during my lifetime
we'll figure out that intelligence,
but I do believe that one of the things
that will happen during my lifetime is
we'll find the seventh kingdom in biology.
I think there'll be a new kingdom that
is not named yet and that kingdom will be
somehow related to the,
to the yeast or the collaboration
between bacteria and fungi.
And we'll figure out a new kingdom lives
on this planet because back in the day
there was not six kingdoms,
there was two and then there
was three and there's four,
there's five now there's six.
And we think biology's come to its end
and there's six kingdoms. And I think I,
my believe is that we'll find
a seventh one. And with that,
thanks for coming and
I appreciate you sharing my knowledge.
Tara,
really quickly,
where can people find you and more
about your product and yeah, I,
we have a easiest is
actually if you're here,
we have a shop on Abbot Kinney called the
shrimp room that serves free beverages.
I know to here at Google is free as well,
but if you want to walk on Abbot Kinney,
you didn't get a free
mushroom tonic anytime. Um,
we are also an all social channels,
uh, at four sigmatic, f. O, u.
R. S. I. G. M. A. T. I see.
I'm a little bit hard to find,
but I have a really bad Instagram called
I am Taro that you're going to follow
my adventures. I post rarely and
randomly, sometimes good stuff,
sometimes not so good stuff.
So that's kind of where you can find us.
But a stop by the Abbot Kinney,
you can find us on whole foods Erewhon
different places here in as well.
If you want to buy it, Amazon
foursigmatic.com we'll figure it out.
Anyway,
thank you.
Sorry.